les marées vertes elles refont surface
sur les plages bretonnes à chaque
printemps
il s'agit d'algues elle pollue elle pue
et pire elles peuvent tuer mais pour
s'en rendre compte il a fallu des
décennies ces algues sont observées pour
la première fois dans les années 60 elle
gagne du terrain dans les années 70 et
80 au départ c'est une préoccupation
touristique et économique à plestin en
1982 le ramassage a coûté 12 millions de
francs c'est un problème qui qui nous
dépasse actuellement et qui a pris des
proportions énormes en notre commune sur
le plan financier notamment sur le plan
financier certainement est aussi ça nous
touche énormément sur le plan
touristique
mais comment prolifèrent ces algues
selon plusieurs études scientifiques
c'est à cause d'une eau riche en
nitrates et phosphates
les chercheurs pensent d'abord à une
pollution domestique dans les années 80
à cause des produits d'entretien mais
ils se rendent compte en 1996 que la
véritable cause c'est l'agriculture
depuis plus de trente ans donc s'est
installé en bretagne l'agriculture
intensive qui a généré des déjections
animales importante qui utilisent
énormément d'engrais et on a réussi à
montrer que la marée verte se développe
parce qu'elles utilisent les sels
nutritifs qu'on trouve dans ces
déjections animales et danser en grec
plus préoccupant ces algues s'avère
meurtrière quand elles pourrissent
elle dégage un gaz toxique l'hydrogène
sulfuré déjà suspecté en 1989 dans le
décès d'un homme
il est à l'origine de la mort par
asphyxie de chiens en 2008 ainsi que
d'un cheval et d'un homme en 2009
réaction du premier ministre françois
fillon
un plan intergouvernementale l'état va
prendre toutes ses responsabilités et va
prendre à sa charge le nettoyage des
plages qui sont les plus touchés c'est à
dire de celles sur lesquelles il peut y
avoir un risque de santé publique
134 millions d'euros sur cinq ans pour
le ramassage la valorisation des algues
méthane et des aides pour encourager les
bonnes pratiques des agriculteurs mais
d'autres décès surviennent 36 sangliers
en 2011 et en joggeur en 2016
la journaliste inès l'hérault a enquêté
sur le dossier elle publie ses travaux
en 2017 sous forme de bande dessinée
elle estime que l'état aurait pu
intervenir plus tôt on a tendance à
accuser les agriculteurs
l'agroalimentaire mon bac et au départ
c'est quand même un programme étatique
une volonté d'industrialiser
l'agriculture et l'état qui n'a pas
voulu entendre les scientifiques lui
disant on est en train d'engendrer des
marées vertes dès les années 80 l'état
qui a fait la sourde oreille qui a passé
cette information sous silence depuis
plusieurs plans gouvernementaux ont été
lancés les agriculteurs tentent de
réguler leurs pratiques
mais pas de quoi freiner les marées
vertes elle aurait même tendance à
s'intensifier avec le réchauffement
climatique
[Musique]